-♪ "Wheel of Opinions" ♪
-Let's start
"Wheel of Opinions."
Here we go.
[ Beeping ]
Oh! Gyms reopening.
What's your thoughts?
-Oh, my God. Thank God.
Where do I take my roid rage?
I get roid rage when I'm doing
crunches in the house.
I will say, my overall opinion
about everything reopening,
like our governor --
I'm in California,
and he's very safe.
So he says, "We're starting our
gradual Phase 1 opening,"
and I'm like, "Oh, great!"
He's like, "So,
it's gonna be rock quarries,
caterpillar sanctuaries,
and then maybe
in a couple years,
gyms, restaurants.
But gyms are -- I don't know,
because they're sort of gross.
I haven't been to one
in five years.
They could have closed
five years ago.
I don't even know.
LA Fitness, Equinox.
I don't mind not seeing
old guys drying
their crotch with a blow-dryer.
[ Imitates blow-dryer humming ]
"Hey! You see the Rams
game last --"
[ Imitates blow-dryer humming ]
Embarrassed. My God.
What's happening?
Alright, spin it again.
[ Beeping ]
-Your topic now is...
-[ Imitates beeping ]
-Oh! Murder hornets.
Murder hornets exist.
-Murder hornets, man.
Let me tell you something.
Regular hornets
are no day at the beach.
All hornets suck.
No one's ever like, "I wish we
had the good hornets here."
Hornets are the worst
bug that -- Hornets.
Yeah, I don't even like to be
around the Charlotte Hornets.
-Let's do our final topic.
Are you ready?
-[ Imitates beeping ]
[ Beeping ]
-Your topic is...Mike Tyson
comeback.
Did you see this?
-This is real. Mike Tyson.
He's on that heavy bag.
-We both did that.
That's how we fight.
Imagine if we fought each other.
[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
-It'd be like
Rock 'Em, Sock 'Em.
-Oh, gosh.
-Tyson -- he is a little older.
And it's gonna air on
pay-per-view on TV Land.
That's the only thing
I know for sure.
I want him to fight --
I want Tyson to fight Fauci.
Let's give him an easy one
right at the beginning.
-Right? No, who is he --
We don't know who he's fighting?
-Yeah, Dr. Fauci.
And then,
once he gets through him --
which I wouldn't look past him,
'cause Fauci's, like, angry.
-Yeah, he's --
-Fauci yesterday was like,
"Uh, it's unstoppable."
I'm like, "I'm sorry.
What'd you say?
"Coronavirus --
you know, it's unstoppable."
I go, "I think this is
bad news, guys."
But Tyson --
I would like to see him,
because I just thought
he was such
a great fighter in the old days.
And he's so tough, and it's just
fun to watch him fight.
He looked --
I did see a video of him,
and he was whaling
this heavy bag.
And I go, "I wouldn't want
a piece of that guy.
He's too good."
-Yeah, he's too good.
He's insane.
You know, he's done our show
before, and we did some bit.
And at the end of the bit,
he came over and he hugged me.
And as we were hugging,
he put my ear in his mouth.
He bit my ear.
-That's hilarious.
-So he did do it.
I can't fight Mike Tyson.
-No, you just lay down.
-Yeah, I just go, "He did it."
I got to maybe laugh
along with it or something.
-Then you go, "We'll be back
with Kathryn Hahn."
-David Spade,
we love hearing from you.
Thank you for playing
this game with us.
Spade, I love you, man.
I'll call you or whatever.
I'll text you or whatever.
-Whatever, buddy.
I love to hear from you. Thanks.
-Bye, pal.